n'ira ni hao cela veut dire bonjour il
est 8 heures ici à pékin 20 heures du
soir et si j'ai choisi un jeune garçon
pour m'accompagner
ce jeune garçon est à l'image de la
chine de cette chine populaire
peuplée de deux centaines et de
centaines de milliers de jeunes comme
lui deux millions même puisque deux
habitants sur cinq dans cette chine 2979
aux moins de 18 ans des centaines et des
milliers de jeunes chinois aujourd'hui
sur la place tiananmen pour assister à
cette édition spéciale de tf1 actualité
en direct de pékin avec moi en costume
les minorités 50 minorités nationales en
chine et je voudrais tout de suite vous
dire à tous mesdames mesdemoiselles et
messieurs ni mènera voilà nous nous
sommes salués à la chinoise
et ce petit garçon va m'accompagner
jusqu'à gérard saint paul sur cette
place tiananmen illuminé c'est en effet
la première fois qu'une telle
manifestation a lieu à pékin sur cette
place tiananmen que j'aurai l'occasion
tout à l'heure de vous présenter vous
souvenez au mois de septembre dernier
nous réalisions pour la première fois un
journal en duplex entre pékin et paris
gérard saint paul était à pékin j'étais
à paris dans le studio de tf1 actualité
13h et nous réalisions par satellite
ce premier duplex pour le journal de tf1
actualité c'était quelques temps plus
tard une autre première
une véritable première mondiale
puisqu'il y a de cela quelques jours
vous en souvenez j'étais avec l'équipe
de tf1 actualité à bord du porte avions
clemenceau cela se passait en rade de
cannes pour les journées de la marine
nationale
et ce jour là pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la télévision chinoise
d
et téléspectateurs à pékin et sur tout
le territoire chinois découvrait une
émission de télévision occidentales
en effet ici même à pékin et quelques
téléspectateurs ont eu l'occasion de me
le dire depuis deux jours
et bien ici à pékin on nous voyait nous
autres de la télévision française sur
les postes bien sûr sur les postes
familiaux mais aussi sur tous les postes
dans les lieux publics ou les télés où
les téléspectateurs sont nombreux à
s'agglutiner autour d'un poste la chine
apparemment donc vous le comprenez
s'ouvre elle s'ouvre à la france parce
que dans quelques jours viendra à paris
l'un des plus grands responsables de la
chine d'aujourd'hui
le président a eu encore fanny premier
ministre visite très importante visite
sur le plan politique capital disent
qu'il s'agit en réalité genre saint paul
du premier déplacement de monsieur
accueil aux fans dans le monde en effet
c'est la première fois que le président
hu wang va sortir de cet immense pays
qu'est la chine puisque vous le savez
l'ouverture a été pratiquée jusqu'à
présent par le vice premier ministre
monsieur deng xiaoping alors c'est
d'habitude monsieur deng xiaoping qui
effectue des visites officielles et les
voyages à l'étranger
eh bien cette fois pour la première fois
donc ce sera le président hu wang et il
réserve sa première visite au président
giscard d'estaing puisqu'il commence sa
tournée européenne par la france il
continuera ensuite par l'allemagne alors